so let's all do to a together and I'm
going to do it from scratch but I'm only
going to do it one rather than yesterday
i'll start to read that instruction
you've got that I hope in your book so
this time I'm going to literally do it
from the get-go you walk into the exam
your calculator is completely cleared
what do you got to do ok so I'm going to
go through this one by the way tell me
if I head gets in the way or it is right
back to my time I'm welcome people here
alright so the first thing I do
everything's been cleared I'm not SAT
mode or anything like that so the first
thing I've got to go is moes n 2 okay
you do it how to reset ok alright ship
nine will say clear you need to take 3-4
all equals four yes and acs to finish
the whole process ok it's like it is
actually important because you've got to
make sure all the other data from
previous questions is out of there
otherwise obviously you'll get different
numbers and everything okay everything's
cleared let's go memos to that would
start and which one of these electric
again the first one because it's just
one variable ok and this will appear now
because everything was clear I'm not in
a frequency mode anymore and if you have
a look at question 2 I don't want a 40
in nineteen thirteen times ok so let's
remember you've got to go shift set up
the one that I want isn't on this screen
so I've got to press down and then you
can see three the stat and one to turn
on frequency mode ok I far so good ok
excellent let's plug in some data now so
this is a little bit laborious but 17
equals four
18 I'm pressing I'm pressing equals that
put in that and it automatically
defaults to one so i'm using the arrows
to go back and change that manually to a
does that make sense yes
ok so I brought my daughter in this and
I'm just going to go back through the
display make sure I look at a double
check that I haven't accidentally
punched the number in the wrong spot and
now they aunty three questions range
interquartile range population standard
deviation i'll talk about that in a
second now you can actually work out
range without your calculator right
because look look at the question look
at the question they tell you what the
lowest score is they tell you what the
highest stories what's the range it's
just full alright so in fact I've
anybody my calculator there so that you
get is right down range equal school but
for interquartile range how do you look
I need to know if the quartiles are now
thankfully rather have to write all this
out the whole point of punching this in
is this will do it for us okay so watch
carefully because we didn't do this
yesterday if I clear it now the data is
still there in the background I'm going
to go shift one to get to all of these
different thing I can get from the staff
right now instead of going to 44
variable that's where i went to standard
deviation i'm going to press 5 1st min
max five okay so you can see here these
options here are going to tell us you
remember the box and whisker pot how
many do you have really okay all right
this I'm almost certain if you check
your calculator model you check your
cargo
yeah so he's already advised okay and I
hate to have to do this but because poor
tiles are such a pain to work out I
think maybe you either find a friend
who's got one of these and on the day
your exam or your assessment just switch
with them keep in mind to unit and
officially introduced today they don't
need to do any of this so if they've had
the same exam with that immense example
10 days view and just talk to calculated
this should be fine okay because you
really want to be able to get your
calculator do this like seriously you
want them to go to do that or of course
if you can find a cheap Adolphus or
whatever get one but for now if you
don't have it I'm going to show you so
again here you can buy them from me but
I'm just saying you got tractor that
already I can understand if you don't
want to buy a whole new one and ours l0l
impossible so the interquartile range I
need two three and I need q1 ok so I'm
going to press five so you get q3 ahead
equals and it lands on 19 so I'm
actually gonna write that down
q 3 equals 19 I'm going to go back and
I'm going to ask the q1 yeah okay now
let me just pause that before I finish
this off an answer the question I can
actually get my calculator to do this
calculation in the second the
interquartile range by getting like
literally punching it's my calculator q3
take away 2 1 equal because watch I can
just press the buttons on my calculator
like so ships 155 there we go okay so
these are just like you know how I
showed you how to use that printing
rules when you calculate the age of
agency these are just like pretty move
and I can hit equals and predictably it
tells you one can anyone tell me why I'm
going to encourage all of you to write
these things and well if you make an
arrow you push something is wrong you
don't want to have just that final line
cyclery yeah yes very good these things
sure I know what interquartile range is
either have calculated it wrong but at
least I know what it's talking about and
that's understanding that you can
demonstrate okay so i highly encourage
you to write things and then do the
calculation rather just entrusting
everything to the calculator I mean it's
not hard to do the subtraction anyway um
so I would distract them okay now that
was interquartile range so let's
remember how do i get the standard
deviation can you help me this time what
I press shift one
for four variable three is that little
weird symbol there and then that's it
now I got the question before about what
working till I put down to this
unfortunately there's really not much
working the calculator has done all the
legwork for you I would however cuz
you're the question asks you to
approximate I would write down that I'd
like down the calculator to play at
least two like should more decimal
places where the question is asking
right so maybe 0.97 75 saw the thought I
think that's enough what is the question
awful just too wonderful place what is
this wonderful careful it's 1.0 right it
was just one that's got no decimal
places on like you know the next one
should be zero so you better influence
Annika